This episode of DNews is brought to you buy
LG G3
Researchers have found a way to make glass
tubes a tenth the thickness of your hair send
cat videos around the world.
Better.
They found a way to do all that but better.
HI!
Julian here for DNews.
Your smartphone is super cool, you’ve got
all the DNews you could possibly want, anywhere.
But you’re not really totally wireless.
You’re within a few miles of a cell phone
tower, but the tower may be hundreds of miles
from the servers where all that juicy knowledge
is stored.
So how do you connect the two?
Why with laser beams, of course!
Let’s begin at the beginning, which is all
the way back in the 1840’s when Swiss Physicist
Daniel Colladon noticed he could shine a light
in one end of a water pipe and it would come
out the other side.
170 years later, modern optic fibers are basically
the same thing, but they use optically pure
glass and are 9 thousandths of a millimeter
thick instead.
You may be wondering, how does light travel
inside water or glass without just bouncing
out and being lost?
The answer is it all has to do with the angle
the light is shone in.
If the light is hitting the walls of the glass
at a shallow angle, less than 42 degrees,
it’ll experience total internal reflection
and bounce back and forth down the glass.
This property of light is the same reason
you can look out over a lake and see a beautiful
reflection, but when you look straight down
you can see into the water.
To make sure none of that light does leak
out, the optical glass is encased in a cladding
with a higher refraction index that can bend
light back into the glass, then that’s put
in a buffer coating.
Each one of these fibers can carry the equivalent
data of 10 million phone calls, and hundreds
of thousands are bundled together and stuffed
in a jacket to make a fiber optic cable.
Because of them you can send a beam of light
to the other side of the planet in a seventh
of a second.
Being able to shoot light through a glass
tube to China is all well and good, but you
still need a way to send information, and
that’s where modulation comes in.
Modulation is when you vary some property
of a wave to encode information.
Then when it gets to the destination, it’s
demodulated to separate the carrier from the
message.
You’ve been dealing with it a lot and you
might not even know it.
FM radio uses frequency modulation, which
is when a wave’s length is altered.
AM is when a wave’s Amplitude is changed.
and the Modem in your house is short for Modulator
Demodulator.
In fiber optics there are a lot of ways to
modulate the beam and send information.
There’s AM, Sine wave FM, Square wave FM,
pulse frequency modulation, which is basically
turning the beam on and off so it can be interpreted
as ones and zeroes.
All of these methods need costly external
modulators, which are costly and inefficient.
But Dr. Radan Slavik, who is a research fellow
at the Optoelectronic Research Centre and
probable Jame Bond nemesis, has improved another
method.
They’ve devised a way of adjusting the current
of the laser beams so they can have better
control of the optical field and send more
information.
Actually the words Dr. Radan Slavik used were,
“Exquisite control… over the optical field
generated directly from a current-modulated
semiconductor laser.”
Tell me he’s not a Bond villain!
There was another awesome breakthrough in
sending wireless signals a few months ago.
I talk about that and a bit more about Fiber
Optics over here.
If you know of some interesting tech in the
pipeline and want us to cover it, let us know
in the comments and I’ll see you next time
on DNews.